in this video I'm going to show you how
to target cellulite on your hips and
thighs most people spend hours at the
gym doing exercises to try to tone those
areas and without any results it's
extremely frustrating and that is
because of this one simple fact it's not
the fat that jiggly stuff on your hips
and thighs is actually not fat now it's
one of two things number one it's a
lymph situation where there's a lack of
lymph drainage the lymph nodes that you
have are it's like an extra circulation
to the body that have there's like these
little nodes that accumulate through
your neck you've lymph nodes through
here for the immune system
you have them through the abdomen you
have them on the thighs are all over the
place and they can create a lot of
inflammation and soreness when you press
in them so a lot of women that have a
stagnant lymph situation in that area it
looks just like cheese it's like a kind
of a jiggly type fluid retentive thing
now I study a lot about planting and
growing vegetables and things like that
and I ran across this book by this
farmer slash physiologist slash chemist
he wrote this book in 1932 and he's
talking about corn growing corn and
having corn having a huge problem with
the corns a drainage system or the
lymphatic system in the corn stalks and
having all these diseases with the
lymphatic system of a plant and
vegetable so I was like wow that's
interesting what is it what's causing
that and then he goes on to talk about
if there's no potassium in the soil the
the plants drainage system becomes
blocked it becomes a problem and like
that's interesting so I took that
information and I wonder if it was the
same in our human bodies that if you
were to consume more potassium I wonder
if that would push them the fluid out
well guess what
sodium and potassium work as a kind of
an alternative opposite effect so if you
high in sodium retain fluid right if
you're high in potassium you can get rid
of the fluid retention so then I looked
at potassium and I want to know how much
potassium our body is needed and I found
out the daily recommendation is 4700
milligrams
that's crazy that's how a lot of
potassium that's what our bodies need
every single day so then I compared what
people consume per day and I found it
was something like a real small like
less than a thousand and you might say
well I eat bananas right bananas have
300 milligrams of potassium well guess
what you need 4700 you'd have to have 12
bananas a day so right there that told
me that hardly anyone is getting enough
potassium and if you have lymphedema or
swelling or edema or fluid in your lymph
and you're not getting potassium no
wonder it's not working so a real big
tip would be to start to spike up your
vegetable content to get enough
potassium to push some of this fluid out
because it happens in plants why
wouldn't it happen our own body
potassium is a real hard mineral to get
to so you would have to consume about 7
up to 9 possibly 10 depending on your
size cups of vegetable to get your
potassium so here's what I recommend
take a blender put some kale in there
put some spinach in there be tops by the
way have the most potassium out of
anything on the planet yeah those little
those little green things off the beet
beet tops and you cut those off and you
put those in the blender and you start
blending you don't juice it you blend it
put a little bit of berry in there may
be blueberry may be strawberry blend it
up with water drink one of those a day
like fill it up here and then drink half
and then drink another half the other
part of the day maybe add some avocados
so there start increasing more potassium
to your diet if that your problem is
lymphatic water retention and then that
problem will go right away so that's one
step right there so try that
the other cause of cellulite usually
happens when you get in your 40s and
your 50s when you get close to menopause
and the reason for that is your adrenal
glands which are little glands on top of
the kidney there's stress glands they're
the backup organ to the ovaries and so
at age 52 or even before that the
ovaries stop working they start stopped
laying or leasing eggs the adrenal gland
because they make the same hormones
start having to do more work and they
start backing up the ovary if they're
stressed out going into menopause that's
when you have a lot of problems with
weight gain after menopause hot flashes
and etc but if there's a problem with
adrenal during that period of time one
of the symptoms is atrophy atrophy what
is atrophy atrophy is a shrinkage of
your own lean body mass at your muscles
your muscles break down your muscles
turn into mush they don't get the it's
hard to tone them so you can have either
that side light could be a fluid
situation or it can be an atrophy
situation where you have loss of muscle
not because you know eating proteins or
exercising simply because hormonal II
it's very destructive on your protein so
what do you do for that situation you
would want to strengthen the adrenals
find something that targets and
strengthens these adrenals and improve
them and part of that is sleeping and
doing the right exercise and aligning
your lifestyle with it with the support
of the adrenal but there but this is
what I'm trying to say is I'm trying to
say instead of just trying to burn off
this so-called fat on your hips why
don't you just fix the adrenal it's a
lot easier okay
so those are the two underlying reasons
for cellulite and I want you to you know
apply some of the stuff I just showed
you and let me know how it works
okay I hope that helped I'll see you in
the next video